Hello and welcome to Python Bytes where we deliver Python news and headlines directly to your earbuds.
This is episode 176 recorded April 1st 2020. April fools. So I'm Brian Okken. I'm Michael Kennedy.
And this episode is brought to you by DigitalOcean. We'll talk about more about them later.
But yeah, let's just catch up a little bit. What's going on? Oh, you know,
this is one of the few bits of human interaction outside of my house that I get is to talk to you
here on Skype video, right? Like, it's a weird time, isn't it? It's totally weird. We normally
don't record video, but we do see each other. And we've noticed as we would contacted us or
connected today that both of us have new haircuts, but they're homegrown haircuts.
I never cut my own hair and it was getting bigger and bigger. And my hair doesn't get long. It just
it just gets big and poofy and it's more like a Q-tip
on top of my head and eventually I just break down,
like I can't do this.
So at first I looked at my daughter who's 19,
I'm like, here's a shaver, you gotta cut my hair.
She's like, no, no, she did an okay job.
And that was really good and then I decided to go back
and it was still quite a bit actually longer than I wanted
so I gave it a second haircutting as well.
And you know, honestly, it's about as good
as the haircuts I've paid for.
So I'm feeling like this might be a trend
that I was forced into, and you're looking good yourself.
- Yeah, so I normally have like a short goatee thing
that I keep, and I just have,
when I bought the trimmer for it,
I just only needed one guard,
'cause I'm, I mean, I didn't think ahead,
and I just like, I don't know where
all the rest of the guards were,
so I only have that like little short guard
for the trimmer, and my wife was willing to cut my hair,
but it's a little shorter than I was expecting,
but I think it's all right.
I don't have to worry about it anymore.
My kids say it's like a peach, so they come by and rub my head all the time.
It looks good.
That's the weird world we find ourselves in.
You know, I'm here drinking coffee out of this Pittsburgh mug, but there will be no
Pittsburgh, right?
PyCon is now officially canceled.
Yeah, that's a bummer.
This might be the first recording since it was actually fully, fully canceled.
At least the first time we spoke about it, possibly.
We might have managed it last time, but there's certainly a tightening up on getting together
for conferences and that kind of thing.
We spoke a little bit about what's going to stick, these changes that we have to have
that are going to stick.
A lot of meetings could just be emails, or they could be remote, or whatever.
I wonder what that's going to do to the conference space.
Yeah, I wonder too.
One of the reactions I heard from somebody was, even if it was to move towards a virtual,
which they were talking about that a little bit, maybe doing a virtual conference, but
that wasn't the thing.
It's essentially canceled.
Although some people are sending in videos,
they're gonna have some people be able to send in
their presentations as videos, so that's neat.
But it's the meeting people.
We interact with people online all year long,
and it's one chance to get together.
So at least with PyCon, I don't think that'll go away.
- No, I don't think so.
For me, it's not about the talks.
I go to talks and they're interesting,
but it's about the stuff that happens in between it.
It's about hanging out with you,
hanging out with people from other places
I don't normally see making those connections
and just stumbling onto things that are like,
oh, I had no idea that this was happening.
Let's talk about that.
That's the value and that's really tough to replace.
- Yeah, it really is tough to replace.
Maybe more video chats will help.
- Absolutely.
All right, well, I guess everyone be safe out there
and follow our lead.
Stay home, even if you gotta cut your own hair.
- Well, let's move on to some topics.
So first off, I was hoping to talk about pyproject.toml.
I think we've, I'm sure we've covered it before,
but the Brett Cannon is, is he still part of the core
or did he get voted out?
I think he's still part of the core at Honchos.
- I think he's on the steering council, yeah.
- Yeah, he wrote an article just released recently
called "What the Heck is PyProject.toml?"
And one of the reasons why he wrote it,
and I think this is an interesting side effect,
is so if you're just joining us,
the PyProject.toml came out of the efforts
with PEP 517 and 518 to define what the file looks like.
And it kind of defines what tools are needed
to build a project and how to build it.
And that used to be mostly just setup tools,
but now there's lots of other tools like Flit and Poetry,
and you can make your own if you want to.
But these are this file.
One of the side effects is people started adding
other, their tool configuration to this file,
such as like coverage and talks.
Now you can put those configurations
into pyproject.toml for those tools,
even though it has nothing to do with building.
And it just saves you from having an extra file,
but even though those tools
have their own configuration files.
And then Black came around,
and Black uses, only has a few configurations available.
So instead of creating their own configuration file,
Black uses the pyproject.toml for looking up configuration
if you want to configure like line length or something.
And so there's been projects that have added
pyproject.toml files for the reason
because they were trying to, they're using Black also,
and now their builds don't work.
And the reason is if there's a pyproject.toml,
even if you're using setup tools,
Pip will look for the build stuff
around that within the file.
So Brett has gone and added,
showed the few lines of code you need to add
to the Toml file to specify how to build with setup tools.
That's the main contribution for this,
but it's also, I think that people ought to
go read the article 'cause it's a good summary
of where we're at right now.
- Yeah, the pyproject.toml is great,
and it's super cool that you can specify things like
here's how you can, say, build the package, right?
It requires a wheel and whatnot.
- Yeah, it's cool, I really like it.
I honestly need to start working with it.
I'm still on the requirements.txt side of the fence,
just waiting for things to shake out,
but it certainly seems like there's a lot of energy here.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Yeah, so definitely a good pick there.
You know, sometimes we talk about awesome things
on Python Bytes, right?
- Yeah.
- And we've even talked about awesome lists,
which are lists organizing various other things,
projects, websites, tools, whatever, around something.
But last time in passing, we mentioned
that there was a cool article by Jack McHugh
where he blogged about the awesome Python bytes,
awesome list.
- Yeah, that was neat. - That was cool, right?
Yeah, so now, Jack has made this a proper GitHub repository
where it has a clear way to contribute to it.
You can do PRs and all sorts of stuff.
And he said he'll be adding personally to the repo
whenever he hears about awesome things like this,
maybe he'll add his own list to it,
which would be very meta, right?
It would just link back to itself.
No, just kidding.
But that's really awesome.
And there's already five PRs from listeners
accepted on this list.
- Oh, wow, that's great.
- Ain't that cool?
People seem to be liking it.
- After we announced it, then we had other people saying,
and I saw some commentary about,
there was some missing that he forgot about.
- Yeah, well, it's just the stuff
that really stood out to Jack in the beginning, right?
So if you want to go back and kind of look through
what some people thought of a year and a half ago
that we talked about that was awesome, you can go there.
And if you look at it, it comes with graphics,
like all good things that present things.
If you can have graphics, guess what?
It's like a thousand words, isn't it?
- Oh yeah.
- Isn't that cool?
- This is great.
- Yeah, it's really, really polished
and you can just flip through and like,
we talked about D-type,
the visualization for Pandas DataFrames.
and there's some nice examples and pictures there.
Really, really good stuff.
So I think it's a great way to explore
some of the stuff that we talk about.
Couple of fun projects I saw on there
that I just remembered, oh yeah, we did talk about that.
It was cool.
It was great expectations for validating
and documenting and profiling data.
Pandas VET, which is a Flake 8,
a linter for opinionated Pandas code.
GeoAlchemy, which is like geospatial databases
on top of SQLAlchemy.
and Vue.py, which provides in-browser Python runtimes
interacting with Vue.js.
So just all sorts of cool stuff there.
And I guess related to this,
although not technically anything to do with that,
is we have a super cool search
over at pythonbytes.fm/search,
and it's really fast.
It even searches our spoken words.
So if you wanna just find something
that maybe we talked about a long time ago
or see if it's covered, throw it in there,
and it'll pop up.
- That's really neat.
I love this because I'm like flipping through this going,
"Oh, I want to go back and check that out again."
>> Exactly. That was like a year and a half and we only spent
half an hour playing with it before we talked about it,
then maybe we didn't use it again.
But yeah, it was cool.
I legitimately enjoyed going through the list here and I thought
listeners might as well if they heard it before or even if they didn't.
>> Yeah, that's awesome.
>> Yeah. Well, I guess you are going to continue a theme a little bit
with your from the pyproject.toml onward.
I have been playing with a project for a while, off and on, associated with testing code called
the Cards Project. And it's a little to-do app thing. It's just a little sample thing,
mostly to play with all of the stuff around Python and distribution and testing and all that.
And somebody, oh gosh, it was months ago and I should have their name here, but
one of the somebody else contributed a pull request to add GitHub actions. So GitHub actions are
a way to you know for you can use that for like CI/CD workflows with Python project with all
sorts of stuff but with especially with Python projects because you know that the building
pipeline is kind of short with Python it's not as complicated as other things so
Often you don't really, it might be overkill to use another CI system.
And so GitHub actions are really pretty cool for that.
And so I incorporated that and then was looking into the last step was,
how do I publish to the PyPI?
I'd really like to add that.
So there's a, I was looking it up and the PyPA, the Python Packaging Authority,
actually has a article written called publishing package distribution releases
is using GitHub Actions with CI/CD workflows.
And so this was like, I'm following through this.
I'm actually ran into some hiccups,
but I wanted to cover it anyway.
My promise is that by the time this goes live,
the cards project will actually be complete
'cause it's almost there.
There's a few hiccups I've ran into.
PyPI requires you to have an email associated with package,
which is kind of annoying
because Flit and pip don't anymore, but PyPI still does.
So I had to do that.
And there's a few other hiccups.
I don't know if I'll write it.
If there's just these, I'll probably just fix them
and have it ready for people to look at.
But if it's too many more,
I'll have to write a new blog post
and I'll associate that with this as well.
- Yeah, this looks great.
And I had no idea about the GitHub secrets.
So one of the challenges is you want to have
your personal PyPI account where you're the maintainer,
admin of that package on pypi.org.
You might not want to contribute that into the source code,
especially for an open source project, right?
- Yeah, probably a bad idea.
- Yeah, that's going to result in some bad things
happening there eventually.
It talks about how to use the secrets settings in GitHub
to store those there,
and then how to pull those out as replacements
in your GitHub actions, which I had never done.
That's pretty cool.
- Yeah, and the workflow that they're suggesting,
which is, I think, a great idea,
is to go ahead and have all,
every pull request or merge to your,
some master branch or to anywhere, any branch,
go through the entire thing
and try to publish to the test PYPI server.
And only ones where you change the tag,
which is where you would change,
you'd change a tag if you change your version number,
that's when it would push to a PYPI, the real one.
But to have that workflow,
even going through the test PYPI,
every time you push something, I think that's a great idea.
- Yeah, it is.
how you got to change the version number or it's not going to let you publish even to
test right?
Yeah.
So I'm not sure.
I still haven't figured out how to get around that.
So we'll see.
Yeah.
Cool.
One of the things I love, I love really great tutorials.
The internet I think is working because of the great tutorials around.
And one of the groups that have put out some awesome tutorials is Digital Ocean.
So Digital Ocean is sponsoring this episode.
And one of the things that they're offering of course is they offer a way to get started
with they offer Kubernetes clusters
and you can do that with DigitalOcean.
But to get started with hosting and running Linux servers
with Kubernetes clusters, that can be a little tricky.
And that's why we want to highlight
that DigitalOcean has launched their new support center.
And this makes it easier to find answers to your questions,
help you get up to speed, get what you need.
And you can search across product documentation
and community tutorials and forums all in one place.
and especially with something tricky
like a Kubernetes cluster,
or really even if you're new to any of this,
it's like their support center is awesome,
got great tutorials.
So visit pythonbytes.fm/docsupport
to see their tutorials,
and of course use pythonbytes.fm/digitalocean
for $100 credit for new users.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Their tutorials are so good
that you can even select different operating systems
in different versions
so that the steps exactly line up
If you're on, say, Ubuntu 16,
you don't have to try to patch that back.
The tutorial steps would be different,
which is, that's taken to the next level.
Very good stuff.
- I've heard some from somebody once before
where they were actually using a different host
and using DigitalOcean tutorials to help them set it up,
and then they finally realized,
why am I giving money to somebody else?
Let's use DigitalOcean 'cause they helped me out.
- That's where our infrastructure is, very good.
Now this next one, Brian,
this one is best seen through pictures.
So make sure you open this up
and we talked through it.
So like I said, all good presentations,
especially stuff that's graphical has pictures, people.
This is amazing.
So this thing that I wanna talk about is called Rich.
Rich text for terminals.
So we've talked a lot about how it's great to have GUIs
and web apps and stuff like that,
that's very visual for the presentations,
which are still true.
But a lot of times you just want something
in a little terminal app command, CLI app.
And it would be nice if it wasn't just all one plain color
or just all text left aligned.
So there's this cool project called Rich.
And Rich lets you have up to 16.7 million colors
for your terminal colors, not just like eight
or whatever it is, red and light red,
like 16.8 million colors.
It supports bold, dim, italics, underline,
strikethrough, and even, please don't use it,
the blink tag.
You can put the blink tag out there.
You can have text that's left aligned, centered,
right aligned, justified, supports like Chinese and Korean,
has emojis, like you can put colon, apple, colon,
and an apple shows up.
You can, as part of a string, put little escapes.
So you can say this word is bold magenta,
and then here's the rest of the words
and just print that thing out.
So you have like inline styling.
Tables, you have beautiful tables, like in the terminal.
- Those are nice. - Really nice.
Those are really nice syntax highlighting for code.
So you can print out Python code with line numbers
and it'll highlight it.
And even has a Markdown support.
So you could write Markdown and it renders it
as its own version of rich text.
Not quite HTML or something like that,
but it has, you know, bulleted lists
and like titles and whatnot,
even as progress bars and logger support
and all kinds of stuff.
Isn't that cool?
- Yeah, the logger handling is actually pretty great.
- Yeah, so if you're working on a terminal app
and you're like, we're just gonna keep it this way,
but I want it to look nicer.
I want it to look a little more professional.
This is like kind of your all-in-one
do a bunch of cool stuff here.
You can even have multiple progress bars
all updating in parallel on the screen.
So if you've got a bunch of downloads,
you can indicate them all happening or something like that.
A bunch of jobs running.
- Sweet. - So yeah,
this is a cool project.
- Might have to add this to cards.
That'd be cool. - That would be awesome.
Yeah, it definitely would.
It even has all of that support for Windows.
If you use the new Windows console or terminal,
I guess is the word that they're now using,
'cause console, I guess, is the old school thing
and Microsoft's like, no, no, we all have terminals now.
And you can go get that from the,
you probably don't have that on Windows,
it's in preview, but you can get it
on the Windows Store for free,
and I link to that as well.
So if you're on Windows and you want a better terminal
in general that supports this kind of stuff,
check that out too.
- Hmm, interesting.
Second, do you know if that'll roll into the normal,
just all releases of Windows at some point?
- I would hope so, maybe.
It's still in beta, I guess we'll have to see,
but it would be nice, right?
It'd be one step closer to parity
across all these platforms, which is always good.
- Yeah, I just use the Bash terminal for,
Bash for, or Git for Windows comes with a Bash terminal.
- Right, nice.
- Speaking of Windows, I guess it's any operating system,
but I'm actually kind of surprised.
This has been on our to-do list for a long time.
A library called psutil.
It's a cross-platform library for process and system
monitoring in Python.
And I'm actually surprised that we haven't really covered it.
We must have covered it in passing a couple of times.
Probably.
But I wanted to highlight it because it
is an amazing little tool.
It's not something I really love when I have to use it.
But things like-- there's time zone control
and multiple computers or services running
on a different machine with Windows.
Like I said, you can use it with-- it's a cross-platform
thing.
You can use this to grab CPU utilization,
memory utilization, disk usage, network,
what ports are being used.
And you can even see all of this information
based on which process.
So you can get like a per process list of CPU usage
and everything within that.
And then around processes, you can suspend and kill
and signal different processes.
So if you're, one of the things that we use this for
is monitoring our build servers.
I know there's other ways to do it,
but this is a pretty easy way to go over to another server
and grab the CPU's usage and memory usage
so we can keep track of all of our,
make sure all of our build servers are working
and not overloaded.
So we use this, it's a pretty cool little tool.
- Yeah, this looks really great.
I think we also talked about it last week,
briefly when we covered a Hytest monitor,
And that was built on top of PSUtil amongst other things.
We didn't cover PSUtil, but like,
it's that kind of tools that this enables, right?
- Yeah, pytest Monitor used that also.
That was, I'm like, man, I think we covered this recently,
but yeah, it was last week we covered that.
It by itself, it's still a really great thing
to use right itself.
And the readme is huge,
but it shows you a lot of different examples
for how to use it.
- Yeah, it looks super useful.
If you're gonna do any automation
and sort of admin sort of work, it looks great.
One of the great things that I love is the cross-platform part because this sort of stuff you can do on, I mean, you can do directly with Windows and with Unix, but, you know, it's different on everything else, on everything.
And so having a cross, I'm pretty impressed that it can even exist as a cross-platform thing, but it can't.
No kidding. Apparently it can and it's awesome.
Yeah.
Definitely, definitely a good one.
So let me ask you this question.
If I'm going to store some numbers, let's say up to 100,000,
how big of an integer do I need to make in Python?
I don't have to make an integer.
They're just there.
They're just there. It's beautiful, right?
But I know that you've done a lot of C and C++, and I have as well back in the day.
And you used to have to really think about that, right?
Like if you saw a negative 32,000 for a number and you thought you were adding to it,
you're like, "Oh, it was a short and it overflowed. Darn."
Well, I guess it's maybe it should be a u short unsigned short. It could be it could hold up to 65,000, right?
like this is something you always had to think about and in python you don't and
How that happens is pretty interesting. I didn't really know the internals
I kind of guess maybe something like what's happening was happening, but I didn't know and so there's a cool article by our pete
Bayani and he wrote it something called how python
implements super long integers.
So for example, if you tried to take two
and raise it to the power of 20,000 in C,
you would get infinity.
(laughing)
All right, because it's,
well, it's bigger than we can hold it,
so it must be infinity as far as we're concerned.
But in Python, it's fine.
It just gives you a 6,021 digit integer
and you don't have to declare,
like I'm working with really big numbers
or anything like that.
And so Python is pretty cool
in how it's transparent with these, right?
- Yeah.
- So this article digs into the CPython source code.
It talks about the algorithms and the data structures
that make this happen.
So basically the numbers in Python are represented
as what's called a pi var object.
So pi object, that's the core type of things in Python,
but this is a variable length one, right?
And so there's a couple of different types
that are like this.
We've got lists, we've got tuples,
but we also have numbers.
And that indicates that they can be of different size
and they can basically grow as they need to.
All right, so Python's numbers ultimately represent
by this thing called a long object
and that has a pi object base,
but then it also has a size and a digit.
And these digits are, I think they're four,
four or eight bytes long.
I remember it doesn't say here.
It's a macro that would expand it,
four, eight, something like that.
But basically it uses a list of digits
and it, you know, initially it just uses one of those,
but then when it gets full,
it adds another and another and another.
What's interesting is their base 230,
not 10, not 16, 230.
- That's weird, okay.
- Yeah, because apparently it can most efficiently use
that's exactly that space of its four bytes or whatever
as individual elements in a base.
So it's pretty interesting.
Like there's this ginormous number.
And if you were trying to represent it in base 230, it's 100.
I'm not gonna read it off 'cause it's really, really long,
but it's pretty interesting how it uses this.
But then when you get into operations, right?
If I'm gonna add two numbers and they're base 230,
like what algorithm do you do?
It's not like base 10 where you normally do the thing
or division or something.
So that's also interesting to think about.
If you look at arithmetic, it's pretty straightforward.
You just add within the digits.
And if you overflow 230, you do a carry over
like you learned in elementary school.
Subtraction is like you do the borrow,
so it's like reverse.
But then multiplication, in order to keep things efficient,
uses an algorithm called the Karastabu algorithm,
which is a interesting way to multiply
two in-digit numbers in different bases and stuff.
And yeah, so it's, if you've ever wondered
how come you don't have to worry about numbers
overflowing in Python.
Here's a cool look inside that,
at the CPython source code and some of the algorithms.
- That's amazing.
- Yeah. - Actually,
that's pretty cool.
- It is pretty cool.
I'm so glad I don't have to worry about it, right?
It just happens.
- Yeah, one of the definite benefits of Python
is this notion of, you know,
developer time is way more valuable than computer time.
So let's figure all this stuff out for everybody else
and then we can stop thinking about it so much.
- Yeah, for sure.
- I had a project many years ago
where I had to work with an FPGA
and the clock system was such that the timing had,
to set the current time, had to divide that out
for a multi radix number.
So it wasn't like base 10 or base 230.
It was each digit had its own base.
- Oh my goodness, that's crazy.
- It was kind of a beast.
It was a cool algorithm, but it was a fun thing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Love this sort of stuff.
- Yeah, this is really cool.
glimpsed behind the curtain a little bit of the red pill.
You go down inside, see what's happening.
One final comment here is
there's some funny little tricks you can play on people to ask
you can like create the number 10
and then create the number 10 somewhere else and ask if those are the same number like
with the word "is"
it's true for small numbers but it's false for large numbers
and that's because Python pre-allocates the numbers
negative 5 to 256.
Oh wow, okay.
When you have a hundred in your program
it's the same hundred everywhere. But if you have 1,226,411, that was made on the spot.
Because these are pointers. These are not just like four bytes on the stack.
These are getting allocated in complicated ways each time. And so they said, look,
negative five to 256. We use these all the time. Let's just make them when Python starts.
Why minus five?
Well, because who uses minus six? Come on. I have no idea. I can see minus one and zero to 256.
But beyond that, I don't really know what they must have some reason.
Yeah, I don't know why.
They probably started with negative one.
Somebody said, well, let's do minus two also.
Let's go hog wild and go all the way down to minus five.
Exactly. Exactly.
Anyway, hey, that's our six.
You got anything, any news for us or any extras?
I have two really quick things.
You know how Microsoft bought GitHub?
That's kind of interesting news a while ago.
And actually people were contemplating the effects that would have on open source and all.
- Yeah. - Well, NPM,
the pip equivalent of JavaScript,
is now, was acquired by GitHub as well.
So just an interesting moving and shaking over there
behind the scenes.
- That's really interesting.
- Unlike PyPA and PIP, NPM was like a commercial venture
or something to that effect to try to bring that order
to the JavaScript side.
And now, so since it was commercial, it's been acquired.
- So NPM is the JavaScript thing?
- NPM is how JavaScript spells PIP.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Okay, quick other one is,
we're going to try to set up a YouTube channel
where people can see both of us talking,
see all the silly stuff that we do
in a fairly uncut, unedited way.
But we're gonna try to put a video for each topic.
So we just talked about the Python number thing,
like just a single video on that.
It'd be easy to share with friends,
it'll be something we put up there.
So we'll have more details with you soon
on the YouTube channel, but I'm looking forward to it.
I think people, it'll give people a new look
and I think it'll be fun.
- Yeah, and then people will be able to recognize our faces
when we are not walking around
because everybody should stay home.
- Exactly, assuming that we continue
to just give ourselves haircuts.
So we look the same.
(laughing)
- Yeah. - Yeah.
- All right, anything you wanna share with the folks?
- Nope, nope, just working from home.
- All right, well, I had this joke about C
and numbers overflowing and like,
Why is it negative 32,000?
Oh, because it's 37,000 positive or something like that.
Right?
Well, here's another one.
And this one is just to kind of make you feel good about yourself
as a Python developer, right?
Yeah.
So this one's visual as a lot of them seem to be lately, but I'll go ahead
and we'll do our best to describe it.
Right.
I'm going to let you be the developer.
So you do the first three.
You got to give a little description though.
Okay.
So the dude's 830 in the morning.
I'm staring at the screen and I comment stupid bug.
And then seven hours later, and this guy apparently grows facial hair really fast
because he's already got stubble at seven, seven hours.
Oh, it must be Linux.
And then the next day his face is red and he's even got more hair.
And he says, JavaScript's broken.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Bob comes in.
Or the other guy comes in and looks at us.
He says, Oh, Hey Bob.
It looks like you forgot a semicolon.
Ah, fix.
(laughing)
- Oh yeah.
- Oh man, yeah.
So that'll be in the show notes.
You can check out the little comic, it's fun.
It's by Eric Burke, nice one.
- Yeah, don't miss semicolons.
- No.
Oh, there's a lot of things I don't miss.
- Although I'm doing a lot more C now, C++.
I gotta do it again.
- Well, it just makes you appreciate
when you get to do Python.
- Yeah, it sure does.
So, and appreciate my time with you,
'cause this is so special.
- Absolutely, thank you.
It's great to get together and chat about this and share with everyone.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Yep.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to Python Bytes.
Follow the show on Twitter @pythonbytes.
That's Python Bytes as in B-Y-T-E-S.
And get the full show notes at pythonbytes.fm.
If you have a news item you want featured, just visit pythonbytes.fm and send it our way.
We're always on the lookout for sharing something cool.
This is Brian Okken, and on behalf of myself and Michael Kennedy, thank you for listening and sharing this podcast with your friends and colleagues.